[Applause]
welcome to culinary genius
today our five contestants who are
confident home cooks will face two tough
challenges to prove their culinary
skills then each brought their favorite
item from their kitchen at home hoping
it will help them here today now
watching their every move and tasting
their every dish is one of America's
most talented chefs Edward Lee all right
tell us what culinary challenges you're
expecting from them today we're gonna
start off with a butchering challenge
the three cooks who perform the best
will move on to the cook-off where I
have a fresh pantry of Indian and
Mediterranean inspired ingredients thank
you very much let's reveal today's
ingredient contestants please lift your
cloches
before Edward sets your challenge here's
chef Gordon Ramsay about how to get the
best from your land today you'll be
working with this amazing wreck lamb
this is the chef's dream cut why because
it presents itself almost like a crown
fit for the Queen I love lamb so much I
actually read them in my own back garden
now when buying lamb make sure you have
a nice firm flesh on the outside but
always look for this light marbling
running through the center of the eye of
the meat that white marbling keeps that
lamb really nice and juicy what would I
do with this today I don't oven roast it
take it out let it rest brush it with
Dijon mustard then dip the whole thing
in brioche crumbs and serve it herb
crusted Edward what is the first big
challenge for a tansy cooks today thanks
Gordon today cooks I want you to French
a rack of lamb first take the skin off
so most of this can be pulled with your
hands at this point I'd want to take
this flap of skin and fat off
gonna slowly trim it and pull and it's
gonna come right off now for
presentation we're gonna French the
bones which means cutting out the meat
in between the bones find where the
bones meet the loin and then go about an
inch above that and I'm gonna take my
knife and I'm gonna make a cut right
across the bone I take my knife and I
run it so that the blade is hitting that
bone flip it over now I know where those
cuts are you want to do it the same side
come right across and just start to
reveal that boat you see if I stretch
the bones out you can see all the meat
that's in between the bones I'm gonna do
one cut going down you're another cut
going down keep your knife as close to
that bone as possible now come across
you got one flap done now there's still
a bit of sinew and fat connected to the
bone so I take the tip of my knife I'm
gonna run it and just start scraping the
bones I'm right to the end pulls right
off
I want them clean as a whistle
now if this is an expert move just use
my towel in my fingers scrape that bone
look at that I can almost see my
reflection on that bone yeah I want six
nice beautiful cuts okay
so get your blade right in between the
bone go in once little right glue it
down one two three four and five and six
now I want to see a little bit of fat
still left on that bone I want to see
the bones beautiful cleaned and frenched
okay back to your stations you have ten
minutes on the clock
let the battle begin so I don't you
leave the fat on or cut it all off lamb
is really tender you're gonna need
something there to insulate the meat or
it's gonna overcook real fast what else
can you do with lamb lamb goes really
well with nice spicy flavors so there's
so many ways to do it
you can grill it you can bake it you can
see you it I Oh we'll take those lamb
chops marinate it in like a Vietnamese
marinade lemongrass soy sauce a little
bit of sugar and bake them in the oven
absolutely delicious all right why do we
check in on our contestants do you look
like you're handling that knife while
have you had much butchering experience
you cook with me no oh okay I've never
had there's a first time for everything
it was my biggest fear thank you
well hello there mile that's a chef a
little birdie told me that your
girlfriend is a profession yeah yes she
is so I got some blackening Cajun spice
Wow a little while ago I did yeah
I don't know how it's gonna go with lamb
but we're gonna get creative well listen
don't think ahead you got to get through
there first and we leave use your ragin
Cajun so it's like you're comfortable
here absolutely
how are you finding this is this
challenging I've never butcher two lamb
before but it's kind of logical stuff
right yeah the feeling off that you're
separating meat from bone
keep at it methodical we're at three
minutes it's difficult to get it clean I
don't think I had this same piece of
land you're not doing bad just keep at
it
remember the demo okay and hurry up
we're running out of time okay
well neither has any bland so I feel
like she's doing okay but she's taking
off a little bit too much fat and how
about miles isn't the professional chef
girlfriend yeah I know I don't know if
she's gonna be with him after this
challenge just one final minute left one
minute one minute I need some chops on
those cutting boards I can only judge
the chop that are on the cutting boards
[Music]
welcome back five contestants have
attempted to impress Edward with their
butchering skills but only three can
make it through to the final round time
to find out what chef Edward makes of
their rack of lamb yeah you have a
couple of really nice ones and you got a
couple that are mango but for someone
who's never done this before
I'm impressed here's the biggest problem
with what you did you peeled off the
entire fat layer if you try and cook
this guess what it's gonna overcook real
fast but otherwise listen you got all
six I would say your girlfriend
shouldn't be impressed you ran out of
time obviously but I will say we
actually listen to me because I can see
if you use a towel to clean the bones
but you removed all the fat so there's
nothing with you I wish you could have
gotten just a few more on there I feel
like they started out really nice and
they kind of get progressively a little
bit worse this is a little bit droopy
your cuts could be a lot more even what
I love about what you did was you left
that fat on there just enough that's
where all your flavors coming from I
wouldn't tell us which three are going
through to the final the first
contestant going through to the final is
juanita the second contestant to go
through is Vanessa the third and final
contestant to go through is miles
congratulations to Vanessa I need to add
miles you are our finalists for today of
course that means that we have to say
farewell to Heather and drew now let's
see what our three remaining cooks are
made of in the final today's three
finalists have to now turn their prepped
lamb chops into a dish so sumptuous that
it convinces Edward to give them the
title of culinary genius so Edward what
are you looking for from our three
finalists all right these are elegant
very delicate cuts of meat do not
overcook them last thing presentation
counts make it beautiful and don't
forget you can use your cooking
implement or ingredient that you brought
from home to help you here today you
have just two minutes in the pantry your
time starts now
cutter what is in that pantry today
there's so much that's gonna go well
with lamb there's polenta
there's broccolini which is gonna give
you a beautiful bit of flavor fresh fava
beans dried apricots
there's pistachios and there's even an
chiles my mind's wandering when I look
to the pantry there's just so many
options contestants we have one minute
left you know remember when the pantry
is closed you cannot go back to it ten
nine eight I use all your kitchen Flair
to create a wonderful winning lamb dish
in just 25 minutes let the battle begin
[Music]
I grabbed Anna's pepper peppers potato
lemon herbs what is this that is a
zester what are you gonna do I'm gonna
zest my lemon okay so I don't get the
white in it describe the dish to me so
I'm going to have a mound of garlic
potatoes and then I'm going to sear the
lamb chops and garlic lemon mustard
listen taste as you go okay especially
if you've never had it before now I got
to figure out what what kind of flavors
go with it all right
why did you pick up from the pantry so I
don't really know what I'm gonna do
exactly I just grabbed a bunch of
good-looking stuff I'm gonna maybe do
mashed potatoes do like a light dusting
of this Cajun spice I made so you are
gonna use that I'm gonna try yeah the
Cajun rub threw me for a curveball as I
didn't know if it would work directly
with the lamb you're starting with lamb
first and then I'm gonna do them
hopefully simultaneously okay I think it
could be risky to do it first but I
thought it was worth it to get it
exactly right what else you got going
here polenta cake and then take on a on
a ratatouille all right you got a lot to
do so time management okay all right
thank you
here we have one ADA who has never
cooked with lamb level even eaten it
before how do you think she's gonna
close it don't listen I don't know how
you're going to pinch me and pick
ingredients for something you've never
eaten before right chest
jobs now Vanessa don't start by cooking
the lamb I don't want to eat overcooked
meat today what would you have grabbed
from the pantry today Oh easy get some
spices get some herbs make a really nice
yogurt sauce spiced away and sear it off
really nice may be popular the low up
and just bring it up to ten sit maybe a
little creamy let the sauce on the
bottom done 15 minutes cooks we have 15
minutes left kitchen here on culinary
genius lamb chops our today's special
and our three finalists are racing to
ensure their dish takes the top spot
let's check it out what are words of
wisdom would your chef girlfriend give
you right at this pressure-filled moment
don't burn anything do you cook for her
she comes home from working oh she's
quite tired now the title culinary
genius what would that mean to you I
like cooking at home my friends like
coming over and eating my cooking so I
guess it would just be another notch and
you could brag a little to your
girlfriend you like hey you're the
professional put on the culinary I don't
know if I do that you seem very calm is
this a place you're very comfortable
yeah I like being in the kitchen I like
my space in the kitchen at home who do
you cook for my husband family and your
husband's here are the you love your
friends wave hello so if you don't
really tend to cook a lot of meat you
said what do you cook a lot of fish a
lot of vegetarian meals I have a
daughter that's a vegetarian and that's
it you grew up in the Philippines is
that right I did how did that influence
your cooking style it gave me a palette
for all different kinds of flavors so I
appreciate foods from all different
cultures and when he said land
Mediterranean was the first thing that
came to mind what would you do with a
thousand dollars if you win today I'll
see if I can get a holiday and would you
take your husband a daughter who I know
are here in the audience I would what is
your favorite dish she cooks she made a
great peanut chicken Thai
I'll always remember excellent five
minutes left everyone Maz what's going
on how you doing yeah coming along here
look at the potatoes out
um the listen I've noticed you're
playing with your hair alone oh okay
stop that you look real handsome you're
gonna still look handsome at the end of
this what are you making what's your
dish rack a lamb with mashed potatoes
and beds all right give me a better name
I will think about it come on your
girlfriend's a chef for minutes cooks
everyone for minutes 180 how's it going
Lamia are you gonna take there you're
gonna cook it you're gonna play me at
this without tasting it I know I did try
it and I was surprised it wasn't bad I'm
doing the lamb chops cooked veggies and
then I'm waiting for my tomatoes and
then I'm like I don't know you're a
wonderful cook do one thing that's a
little bit elevated than what you
normally would do at home okay Vanessa
why didn't you do something Filipino I
love Filipino doesn't matter man you've
just some key no I'll do some adobo all
right this is presentation please make
it look beautiful make sure that land
doesn't overcook okay yeah they got a
hurry up mouse is too busy trying to
look good in front the camera than
making this food look good
Juanita she's got a really good
confidence going but I want restaurant
style food not wound cooking yes I
doubted Vanessa's lamb chop but you know
what she did was really smart she pre
steered her lamb chops and now she's
recruiting them so I think they're gonna
be okay but that ratatouille is not
looking anything like any rat the two
I've ever seen before
just one final minute clean plates
everyone please make it look artful and
let those flakes shine it's one minute
to go and I don't know how I'm going to
plate this dish all right 30 seconds
flavor flavor part of culinary genius
where it is time for Edward to judge our
cooks dishes let's get in there I think
it looks pretty I think it will have
flavors that may not really go with lamb
but I think it complements the lamb
[Music]
looking at my dish and then the amount
of time I had to do to accomplish what
I've done I've been pretty happy with it
it's very colorful and the lamb looks
perfect where does the idea come from
Greek it's a Greek or grandma all right
first of all I feel like I'm in a lovely
French restaurant very beautifully
plated this is looks like a Christmas
tree on top of national potatoes so
we're not there my thing is if it's not
edible don't put it on the plate your
sauce it looks a little grimy I know
that's all flavor what you can do is
throw some butter into a pan maybe add a
little bit of cream olive oil whisk it
in there and you'll have a nice textured
body sauce
I think you should rename this dish yeah
yeah it's really delicious um you used
yogurt dint you okay really smart move
it kind of gives that a brightness that
it means here's what you did wrong
you picked one that's really thick and
one that's really thin so the list lamb
perfectly cooked you see how pink and
juicy this on the inside this one
totally drawing okay but for someone
who's never cooked lamb before this is a
really nice dish
way to go on eat it thank you you had a
million vegetables on your station and I
only see two what happened to the other
Richard yeah the time just got ahead of
me this is a small potential
girlfriend's a chef he kind of had this
backwards the bones usually go together
and then the meat flares out versus the
other way around much nicer all right so
let's go in for a dive okay the lamb is
nice and moist I actually wish you would
have put a little bit more of the rub on
there cuz it could have used it but so
far you have the juiciest cut of lamb so
good for you thank you you kind of went
sort of avant garde with your lamb chops
I like the way you use the ring mold on
the polenta very professional very nice
let's go in for a taste
okay so you really just parked with your
lamb chops tell them off to the side you
finish them in the oven and what you got
was a really nice beautiful pink
medium-rare lamb chop which I'm very
impressed with because this is how we do
it in restaurants as well your faux
ratatouille is actually pretty good it
really could have used a zucchini it's a
little boring because it's just eggplant
and tomato there's so many things in
that larder that you could have used
nice dish
pretty good not a 100% Mediterranean but
really nice Edward has now picked his
Victor
[Music]
to reveal today's winner finalists
please lift your cloches
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Vanessa this was so close but what put
you over the edge was the technique of
pre searing that lamb you had the best
cook lamb chops today genius thank you
[Applause]